in 1963 officials with India's space
agency were still moving rocket parts
around on bicycles
in 2023 they successfully landed a
spacecraft on the moon this
accomplishment was especially emotional
because four years ago in 2019 a
software glitch caused its predecessor
chandrian tuselander to crash into the
moon's surface so they were nervous this
time understandably so in fact I was not
that much confident because as a person
who has been doing in this in this
domain for 36 years I know there are
thousands of things any of that could
can anytime go wrong and derail the
pressure was immense admitted the
director of the center that spearheaded
the construction of the spacecraft the
amount of effort is tremendous
Smiles that filled the room were a
testament to the resilience of the
trondreon 3's team who navigated the Vic
Ram Lander to avoid all those potholes
to come in for a soft Landing this
footage has been super sped up the Rover
pregon then rolled out of the Lander's
belly to begin exploring the lunar
surface and we became the first country
to go to the near to the South Pole of
the Moon
astronauts are racing to get to the
lunar South Pole as spacecraft have
detected water ice there which can
potentially be extracted and turned into
drinking water food and Rocket Fuel NASA
desperately wants to land humans there
before China I don't want China to get
to the South Pole first with humans and
then say this is ours stay out
while China has exceeded Russia as the
most significant rival to American
influence in space India is emerging as
a force to be reckoned with India's
small and Scrappy space agency is
growing more powerful by the day it
started off small by launching
Satellites after establishing its Space
Program in 1962 four years after NASA
under the leadership of the late
physicist Dr Vikram sarabai the lunar
lander Vikram was named in his honor a
tribute to his vision which he described
this way there are some who question the
relevance of space activities in a
developing Nation to us there is no
ambiguity of purpose we must be second
to none in the application of Advanced
Technologies to the real problems of man
and Society initially India space agency
which later evolved into ISRO
collaborated with multiple countries
that iconic photo from 60 years ago is
part of an American-made rocket
transporting Parts by bike is a
testament to India's resourcefulness
when I mentioned on X said the chandrian
3 budget was less than that of the movie
Interstellar Elon Musk replied good for
India by the way let's connect on X I'm
at Muse think the link is in my
description India space agency has
always worked on a shoestring budget
while NASA's Mars probe Mission Maven
cost 671 million India's Mars Pro
Mission Mongolian cost just 74 Million
by the way India became the first
country to successfully reach the red
planet on its maiden voyage in 2014. the
entire Indian Department of space budget
for 2023 is one and a half billion for
both civilian and military use a
fraction of NASA's 25 billion dollar
budget or the U.S space Force's 26
billion dollar budget to be fair NASA's
much larger budget is a reflection of
its size and accomplishments they've got
astronauts in orbit the U.S is the only
country to have landed astronauts on the
moon albeit the last time was 1972 and
they're now trying to send humans back
to the moon and one day to Mars although
the U.S spends more on space as a
percentage of GDP than India compare
America 0.28 to India's 0.04 percent
it's much less than what NASA spent
during the Glory Days which was over
four percent of the total U.S budget for
India doing more with less is possible
because of its cheap labor market we are
aerospace engineers might just earn a
thousand dollars a month which is not
even minimum wage in America a lot of
the technology used by ISRO is also
developed in its own country rather than
than being imported it used to rely on
the French space agency CNS to supply
parts for its liquid-fueled rocket
engine vikas which Powers various Israel
launch vehicles but now the engine is
made in Mumbai by the company godrej
Aerospace in a suburb of the sprawling
City it takes about five months to
create an engine and then it's shipped
to ISRO by Road at a careful pace of 20
kilometers an hour or 12 miles an hour
taking two weeks to go from Mumbai to
isro's Vikram sarabai Space Center
interior of anemtapuram another way
India keeps its space agency light and
Nimble is through shared launches think
ride share with other countries in the
space industry where multiple payloads
usually satellites hitch a ride on a
single launch reducing India's overall
costs ISRO has had commendable successes
until now but landing on the moon has
marked a Monumental leap for the nation
showing its capabilities on the global
stage we will be now looking at putting
the man in space putting yes craft
around the
ear and Landing your craft in
India has actually never sent people to
space on its own an Indian astronaut or
viomana as they call them flew into
orbit on a Soviet rocket in 1984. India
is preparing its first astronaut mission
called gaganyan which aims to send three
astronauts into orbit on its own
spacecraft but the mission has faced
delays and ISRO hasn't announced a date
for it
as the curtains Drew to a close on the
20th century the Cold War Space Race
gave way to a new race
the U.S Remains the dominant player with
private companies notably SpaceX shaping
the landscape of space exploration
China is watching spacex's every move
and aims to create its own answer to
spacex's fully reusable rocket Starship
Russia now lags behind symbolized by its
lunar lander crashing into the moon mere
days before India's Triumph India may
have been late getting into the game but
it has proven it has plenty of potential
we'll continue to do our best and make
our flag fly is
yes thank you very much
one of my favorite parts of a successful
mission is seeing the team's reaction if
you're inspired by what these Engineers
have achieved and want to develop
similar skills or brush up on what you
already know brilliant is a place to
learn brilliant is website and app where
you can learn math computer science and
data science interactively you can dive
into their mathematical thinking course
by seeing fractions percentages and
ratios in a new light if you're new to
programming the thinking and code course
gets you designing simple programs like
map navigation I like to take a few
minutes out of my day to go through
their logic puzzles to improve my
analytical thinking skills so why not
give brilliant a try it's free for 30
days by heading to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink the first 200
people to sign up through my custom link
will receive a 20 discount on Brilliance
premium annual subscription unlocking
all of the courses thanks for watching
I'm Cindy Palm